Hello, Jubilee and all the Goodhumans out there.
- Hi, Jubilee.
[Everyone talking over each other in different languages; they're introducing themselves]
At the moment, what's really scary to me is the fact that no one really knows how to handle the whole situation
Cause, my job got shut down for two weeks
My mum lost her job
Dominic's job got cut
And we lived paycheck to paycheck
I'm almost afraid of what I don't know
What's coming in the future
[Everyone talking]
Uncertainty, Uncertainty, Uncertainty
This is the longest I've really had to spend with my thoughts
I have recognised some self destructive behaviour.
I myself struggle with depression
And I'm home and there's no people around me. I really don't have a good way to distract myself.
Our family life hasn't been...well melding together. And...*sighs* I'm emotionally breaking down
Where I work is insane.
At 6:30am there's already people waiting outside. It's ridiculous.
We are literally risking our lives for this.
We saw a disturbing rise in hate-filled attacks.
Right now I'm most afraid about my own health because I have underlying medical conditions.
I have a chronic auto-immune illness
I also have Type 1 diabetes
I'm missing a part of my lung so if I catch COVID-19 I could possibily die.
My parents, my dad, my sister, I have a newborn baby brother
My mom is a nurse. My dad is still working and his company won't give him a leave.
My dad has a history with cancer. My mom is immunocompromised.
What I am most afraid of right now is my loved ones getting sick and particularly my boyfriend getting sick because he has a lot of health issues that really put him at a higher risk.
Because currently, my mom is still working. I wish she could stay at home and not have to work so hard because I can sacrifice not graduating. But I can't sacrifice my family
Right before I started recording this video my grandpa was shipped off to hospital because he had a fever, shivering...couldn't control his body.
It's not looking too good and I'm honestly really scared right now.
I called my dad about 5 days ago and apparently he had been sick for quite some time and he didn't tell me. When he got tested it turned out he was positive for COVID-19.
It's so different when you can literally hear someone's shortness of breath through the phone...
[Sirens]
I have a lot of questions in my head
[Starts crying]
You don't get to just stay with them to see them get better or you don't get to say goodbye
You just see a number..
You don't get to celebrate who they were. You don't get to show how much you loved them.
There's a white blanket hanging outside. It's a sign of reuniting with the caregivers. As you can see there's people out here on the window.
So everyday here at 8. Everynight at 10:00
Around 6pm. At 8:00
The medical staff, doctors, nurses, scientists and researchers. The people who are endangering their own lives
Truck drivers and the grocery store workers. They are the unsung heros
(cheering and clapping)
"You are my hero"
San Diego Girl Scouts answered the call by sewing homemade masks
So many people who don't have anything to do with eachother have now something to share
That's I think has kind of a strange beauty to it.
The fact that how much we still grasp to life even if death's just walking the streets that we knew so well
The fact that we still want to love, to smile, to see people live, to enjoy life even if we're in our houses
"Here to welcome our first COVID graduate.
[Applause]
[Singing]
The small acts of resilience
or the unity that I feel with my fellow citizens.